what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don shotgun super pumped
to be talking about building the new
world with blockchain and
decentralization we have Jim marcano
joining us on the show hi Jeff it's a
pleasure to be here thanks a lot Allan
it's a pleasure for us to have you on
the show also in your home who are just
so nice thank you
you guys are great tenants I'm glad to
be supporting your work thank you very
much and we're also super pumped to talk
about your work for those who don't know
Jim's background he does business
development for blockchain companies
coming to Japan
originally a software engineer he is
very passionate about the technology
behind blockchain and decentralization
trying to increase awareness of this
important paradigm shift you can find
Jim's links in the bio below it is
LinkedIn and Twitter profile Jim I want
to start things off by talking about
this a very big picture we're having
this massive paradigm shift happen I
think people are starting to understand
more and more what it meant to have
centralization of power now things are
becoming decentralized give us this big
abstract perspective on what the
centralization of power initially was
and now we're moving to the
decentralization right so you know we
why how did centralization come come up
what is the why did it come about right
previously when we're doing transactions
you know if we're not doing it face to
face you know we have to rely on this
intermediary so maybe you know I want to
send money to somebody if I can't see
you in person I have to send it over a
bank or if you any kind of transaction
you know if we're not gonna do it face
to face react we usually use an
intermediary over time those
intermediaries get more and more
powerful they start increasing
transaction fees they start censoring
transactions oh you you're not allowed
to send money to him or it's gonna cost
you this they end up having a lot of
power now sometimes that's good you know
they can maybe enforce the law or maybe
enforce a certain level of service but
more than not these intermediaries have
kind of grown out of control in our
society and they add a lot of hidden
costs in all
kinds of you know transactions so that's
that's kind of how I like to see the
context for why we need like
decentralized third parties and so kind
of nowhere before now was there this way
to do a peer-to-peer transaction but not
in person you know with you how to trust
this intermediary but thanks to
blockchain you can do this in a way
where we both agree on some terms in
advance and then with as soon as long as
those terms are met some transaction
will automatically occur and it's
basically unstoppable no one can change
your stop it after we agree to those
terms and so that type of transaction
there's different words for it but for
instance etherium would call that like a
smart contract so using this aetherium
blockchain we can agree on some terms to
do some kind of business operation and
then it once we commit to that it
automatically executes so that's kind of
how I look at it and but then if you but
what makes me passionate about it is you
see like how our society is in such a
need for this type of technology right
like you know if I want to send money
Western Union to South America they
charge me this huge rate I have to agree
to their terms I can't send it to
certain people that's that's the easy
example but there's all kinds of
intermediates you didn't even realize
we're there and you know it's gonna take
time but basically a lot of those
intermediaries will be either reduced or
eliminated and the the fees there
they're incurring and the power they
have will shrink maybe getting to the
point where you know we don't need them
anymore and then we also can own once we
create this network of value we can be
owners in that network of value as well
instead of a lot of times the
intermediary owns the business and it's
very successful and they are the one to
reap all the rewards but using the same
concept that the users and the providers
of liquidity in this network can also
kind of own the network and share in the
rewards but that's a little bit
different thread and you give this you
gave us a couple examples but one of the
most I think important examples is the
way that we exchange this thing called
money this one is one of the most
important ones this one of the most
important applications of what
decentralization
nology can do for us eliminating the
third party from the process and giving
the power back into people's hands but
again one of the things that comes up a
lot is well right now we have all this
faith in this currency that we use all
of a sudden although it is yes numbers
in a digital ledger in a centralized
banks digital ledger now it's well what
if we just transition those numbers in
the digital ledger to a cryptocurrency
rather than the fiat currency and then
we have the blockchain that enables us
to be able to very very immutably store
those transactions the way that the
money is moving over time do banks even
currently have a storage mechanism like
that where they can see these traces of
money well and that's that's part of
reason why it takes like three days to
do wire chancellor because they've got
these batch processes that run and then
they get audited and checked and make
sure no one modified it because you know
and somebody get in it gets very
complicated um but one thing I just want
to say is that you know simply changing
to a blockchain is not you know there
could be centralized or permission block
chains you know like the government
could say oh we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna make a blockchain that we
control right a black-bean does
necessarily imply decentralization it
can be a centralized blockchain
but what we're aiming for yet is is like
a decentralized mod it's a ledger for
money that's not in control you know for
instance the some government central
bank could could create a blockchain
based digital currency for their country
but they could decide all the rules
themselves we're gonna they could still
make it just like the traditional and
we're gonna control who's allowed to use
this blockchain and we're gonna inflate
the currency if we want you know like
there's nothing stopping them right but
you say like Bitcoin well it's fixed at
21 million bitcoins I can't change that
right anybody can participate they can't
block someone from participating so
that's what gives it these nice
qualities but you could you could make a
bad you know watching a very centralized
blockchain as well
again this big promise of being able to
do something like take and put power
back into people's hands on a
peer-to-peer cash transfer is so so
important yet also this is just one of
so many of the applications unlike this
this is big history perspective it's so
interesting looking at the origins of
money how money even came to be then
what we're actually doing with it today
how it even works one of the things that
so many wealthy people talk about is
when you're not educated about money in
school then you become poor when you
educate yourself about money you have a
much higher propensity to earn money to
gain money to become wealthy these types
of things
what are stocks what are investments
into real estate into all different
aspects how do you diversify portfolio
what are those things how do you save
money what's compound interest but then
what is this money backed by or is this
a shared hallucination of money what our
cryptocurrencies are they also in a
sense of shared hallucination that is
maybe just a little bit immutably
stronger in a sense and then what are
the other applications that can come
from a blockchain style of life where
like we initially did thousands of years
ago of exchanging things of that we
wanted and we wanted to make sure that
the other person got the item and we got
the compensation for the item now things
are happening digitally with these
exchanges you or you are in the process
of selling a vehicle right there's these
ideas of can we just smart contract this
out skipping yeah so there's all these
different applications as well yeah
there's a rose are a lot of great points
just kind of unwrapping a few of those
first on the whole like do you need to
back it or not you know of course I love
commodities you know I think gold and
silver they're very nice you know
they're tangible the price is
manipulated it's unclear of the quantity
that's out there you know they they and
it's just you can't really buy and sell
it right you've got it
how do you splice it up how do you store
it how do you send it you know it's good
maybe if you're gonna store it in your
in your secret stash or vault or
something but it's not it's not as
practical for our current society
although I'm not trying to to criticize
commodities
but the thing about you know say Bitcoin
or other decentralized cryptocurrency x'
is okay yeah they're technically not
backed by anything but I would argue
that that's actually a benefit because
trying to back it with something
actually adds a point of failure like
say you're gonna make digital golden
you're say I'm gonna have a blockchain
with the cryptocurrency we're like one
unit of this coin is one ounce of gold
but it's like you're actually tying into
the real world now you're giving
yourself a weakness well is that vault
audited you know is that is that money
there is that ounce there at all times
like who audits that you know there's no
way to check that in code right like
you're relying on someone you know honor
to say yeah we actually have one ounce
in that vault and it's always there like
we promise we do we're if it's really
purely digital you just look at the code
right like look at the Bitcoin code
there's only 21 million Bitcoin no one
can change that they unless everybody in
the network agrees to change it and
they're not gonna do that because it
would change the rules no one would
enter this economic incentive they don't
have and no one would agree to that
because it's not in their economic best
interest basically then the
cryptocurrencies don't necessarily need
to be backed by anything right so I
think that's one kind of error in
thinking it's like people think what's
got me backed by something but like
backing it by something actually makes
it weaker because now you're tying it to
a physical thing that need to be audited
so but making it a deflationary currency
yeah I don't know I kind of don't have a
strong opinion on that or not it's true
like what's gonna happen Bitcoin like 30
years from now when it they stop making
new ones like it's just gonna go through
the roof some cryptocurrencies are
constantly adding more every year and so
I'm not an economist you know at least
you know the terms like it can only be
inflated by this much per month we're
not in for deflated you know by this
much over you know forward 30 years
those terms can also change well but
everybody would have to vote on that
children know they'd have to fork a new
set of rules into the system and that
wouldn't that wouldn't be an easy
procedure but it's true it could it
could change but people if you say are
gonna act in their best I can in their
self-motivated economic interest you
have some faith that like they wouldn't
just make a really change that would
cause everybody to lose faith and the
currency cause that value to go down so
that that's one kind of topic that so I
thought that I wanted to pick up on that
that you were saying and one other thing
I also just wanted to say is it's the
whole financial
inclusion aspect of it I couldn't touch
on it before but not only can the
intermediary censor or withhold or add
fees or choose the marketplace pricing
but they can also say well you know
you're not in our country we're not
going to serve you right all the it's I
mean everybody knows they're going back
to the unbanked side where it's like
with a cryptocurrency wallet you know
all you need is a smartphone or a
computer and you can be anywhere in the
world and now you've got a bank account
basically you can go and do some
Mechanical Turk or TaskRabbit type
bounty tasks for somebody in a rich
country you can get paid in some
cryptocurrency in Africa right and so
they they say like it's it's enabling
like global Kanu generation of global
commerce with inclusion for all less
friction those are some of the the
talking points that that people like to
toss around as well I think we were
talking about this a couple days ago as
well when we were talking about how cool
it is to do things like be able to split
up the assets into really tiny fractions
and then to be able to pay five or ten
or a hundred dollars into ownership of
these rapidly-growing assets which then
also gives people the ability to come in
as a stake holder and just inclusive
stake holding in general but then you
give this example of all it takes as me
to have a mobile phone with an internet
connection and a cryptocurrency wallet
for me to be able to do things like do
tasks to earn to earn money and also you
know we were we just had a bio on the
show and we were talking to him as well
about just this interesting
philosophical point in general about how
everyone just looking at the United
States or China or many different places
and just saying we want to compete we
want to be like unlike the developed
Bing world developing like that is not
necessarily just all that great in
general period so this also goes to
thinking about new systems and just new
ways of living life in general that
don't necessarily need to funnel into
the economic machinery that is trying to
be
don to say that why don't you earn this
you know these couple bucks by spending
your time on on the specific tasks as
well um we were i wanted to also spend a
little time on this one with you this
this we we we have for the longest time
been exchanging things of value and then
not necessarily following through with
someone else about what that thing that
agreement was then we had these notaries
or lawyers come into place that then
wrote these things into code that we
then both signed and then we put things
into escrow made exchanges these types
of things and now it seems like i can
just download a document from the
internet and now pay three dollars or
whatever for that document and then do
the exchange on a blockchain like
aetherium and then you give me your car
i give you five thousand bucks and it
can just be like we're getting close to
that you know it's still you know right
now there are companies that are working
on either libraries of smart contract
templates that you can use to create
these common agreements i think there's
I think there's I don't know if any of
them have really been completely fleshed
out and caught on yet but there are many
working on it because otherwise you'd
have to you know program some smart
contract yourself with these conditions
but it requires you know being it
software engineer but we're seeing that
people are working on both libraries
templates that you can eat like what you
know you can go online get legal
templates kind of some like go online
and get a smart contract template right
and then we both you know sign it using
our our you know cryptocurrency wallets
and then we or we put some deposit into
it you know and then it holds it until
some conditions are met and then you
know does it or also there's also
technologies that are actually trying to
translate like human contracts into
smart contracts some of them require a
certain amount of like user assistance
others just try to use natural language
processing and and then create you like
oh this is what we think the smart
contract version of your legal contract
is maybe make some changes and so a lot
of people are working on that but I
don't think any of them are really you
know live with lots of case studies yet
but we're definitely getting there you
also mentioned
developing yet developing nations and
it's true you know a lot of these
blockchain use cases maybe initial or
initial users are probably better in
developing nations because they have no
infrastructure and it's like they are
much more in need of it we're trying to
replace like you know a payment system
in a developed country well it already
works there's a lot of vested interest
in keeping the system as it is but like
going to a small new country that
doesn't have the same type of network
it's a great opportunity kind of like
get these things running and then kind
of export it to the rest of the world um
which is why you see the like Estonia
succeeding yeah such a digital citizenry
even like hundred Olympians yeah Stoney
uh like places in Africa you know
because they just didn't have or even
India and like Southeast Asia they
really need these these systems more
like Land Registry is a big one where
you know like a lot of countries they
don't know who owns what land and the
government is a really bad keeping track
of in there's all these claims after you
buy it sometimes no I'll own that and
maybe you can't trust the government the
government is corrupt but what if you
put it in a blockchain everybody could
see all the transactions and you maybe
don't even need the government in the
end you know how does it government
adapt to that but it really can force
all the parties to be honest by putting
the Land Registry in a blockchain and
it's so simple and cheap than trying to
make some paper process that relies on
employing a lot of people who could be
corrupted and there's the mechanisms
that prevent someone tampering with an
immutable ledger of my property being
this piece of land in this city well ok
that's the beauty of the blockchain
right people say like you know
traditionally we've had to share do they
call like a distributed decentralized
database but the problem with that
usually is that there still is some
database administrator and that database
administrator can go in there and change
records if they're dishonest or cheating
or a hacker can go in and also get that
right access and go in there and
maliciously change records but the whole
beauty of this block chain with the
chain of blocks you know each block kind
of has a snap like each cryptocurrency
is a different time interval but like
Bitcoin is about ten minutes it's like
each block contains the last ten minutes
worth of transactions and the thing is
there's something called a cryptographic
hash function which basically says like
if I have
know these thousand transactions here's
a number that represents those thousands
like maybe it's like you know like a 20
digit number and if you change one
little bit less transactions it's gonna
change this 20 digit number so like this
is called a hash function and so what
they do is they embed like the hash of
the previous block in the current block
and they just keep doing that all to the
chain so if you try to change some block
that was like you know ten blocks ago
you'd have to go and recalculate all the
in-between blocks and basically in case
of Bitcoin it would take so much
computation it would be impossible so by
using this cryptographic hash function
and this chain of blocks you're
basically making it computationally
impossible for someone to go back and
change the past now someone can try to
attack like the current block but you'd
basically need to control like in
different different cases could be 51%
of network or 67% of the network and
well that's just again these discussions
about security but the idea is that well
hopefully it's it would be impossible
for me to like double the amount of
computers mining bitcoins so I can
attack Bitcoin now maybe you know you
could try to there you know people might
try to scheme ways to do that but it's
kind of these are some of the ways that
it's secure and so by doing that the
kind of guarantees no one can go back
and alter the past and so that that's
kind of this fun part of the fundamental
debate innovation they call it like
double spend how do I know I'm not
spending the same coins twice or going
back and modifying some Wallaces
transaction it's basically next to
impossible yeah yeah so the
cryptographic hash function is the
paradigm that exists today that can't be
tampered with until something like the
quantum supremacy is achieved by Google
which they just released content on then
it gives them computational ability to
do so well there's different there's
different hashes and some of them are
more quantum resistant than others
quantum resistant Yash's yeah what an a
point okay so if one of them does none
of them have like fallen victim to
quantum computing yet it's true it could
happen in the future I'm not a quantum
computing expert but what I've heard
people say is you know if it looks like
one of them is getting is getting Chris
to be broken by quantum computing then
that blockchain will just hard fork to a
different hash algorithm and I don't
know like are they good I don't know how
that impacts the past coins but
basically they would they would MA
fire the algorithm to use a quantum
resistant hash function and there are
ones that are supposedly more quantum
resistant but I'm not a cryptographer
really but you're we just have to watch
that but that that right there is how do
you make a quantum resistant hash
function how do you make it so
sophisticated and successful but then it
becomes resistant to the potential
malicious attacks of quantum computing
it's this is a very interesting
conversational point because so many
people are deciding to invest their
money into things like crypto currencies
and then and then just believing that
it's absolutely certainly never ever
ever going to have a massive issue like
that but the computational power of
quantum computation is just rising so
quickly and that one is that one's a big
one there's a little risk but people are
you know trying to stay you know people
are watching it very closely but yet
nothing is I like that the quantum
resistant hashes everybody yeah yeah
yeah I'm not a cryptographer but let you
know it's so mathematical but it's so
important for decentralization and yeah
securing the transactions because you
don't want anyone to know all about this
you don't want any third party bill to
interfere with what we've chosen so then
how do you know then how do how do when
I register this wallet how do you know
then that it is the funds in this
specific wallet but then you don't
associate that wallet with my unique
identifier of my name and then similarly
with when you were talking about the
piece of land how do you not identify
your name with this piece of land well
you actually can write like you get
basically like a public key and a
private key for your wallet and that
like the private key is some number that
only you know and the public key is
another number which everybody else
refers to you by and so you just pass
out that number to a lot of other people
and they want to do transactions with
you you only know is that number you
only give out your public key to other
people your private key only I know
right angle e you know and you don't
even digitally see ya you don't even
want to take a picture of it or ya
of it yeah right it store it somewhere
very very safe and so but so pop public
key wise can be widely distributed and
that is how people pay you from their
also public key to public yes right
payment right right and so they call it
like pseudo anonymous and then their
their wage people are trying to
obfuscate that and add privacy which is
a separate discussion but let's just go
with the simple case of the pseudo
anonymous public keys
you know I'm number you know 12 you're
number 32 and you know people can see
that $0.12 32 12 it did it transact were
32 but they don't know who is 12 but who
is 32 but you could actually say like
well I'm going to sign some other
transaction voluntarily stating my ID or
I could say like oh well Jim is
associated with 12 and I'm gonna sign
some message with my private key which
only I can do and then they're like well
Jim says 12 says he's Jim well that's
still you're trusting me but you could
trust a good trust a third party could
be a government or a bank or somebody
and that third party could vouch for it
too and say I met Jim and I looked at
his ID and he's definitely 12 and they
could sign it and then like but so they
call these attestations but each you can
have multiple parties attest to other
people's information of course you're
trusting that party that it tested to it
but it might be someone you can trust so
you could let this is kind of this room
they call this a self sovereign identity
so like I can have all these I on the
same wallet number you know number 12 I
can have my name it's tested to I could
have my my salary tested to my payments
on time attested to they can all be
linked to me but the beauty about
blockchain is that they're all encrypted
in I can allow other people to see that
or not so it's like maybe I have this
attestation that says number 12 is Jim
as proved by the United States Post
Office but it's kind of hidden by
default and if I want to allow you to
see it I can I can give you permission
then you can go in and check you can
give just one public kind of popped in
for this one access tation you say like
yeah then when the post office attested
to the fact that I'm Jim here's this I'm
gonna I'm gonna allow you to see that
one bit of data and then you can go in
and prove oh yeah but it's the post
office that it tested it but otherwise
it stays private so this is this kind of
opt-in privacy model II called soft self
sovereign identity where
soft sauce on identity yeah it's a big
blockchain buzzword - so you control all
these profile attributes and who can see
them under what conditions otherwise
they're all encrypted basic until that
gets leaked if possible like if you do
yeah a little so soft cells just self
sovereign adjust self sovereign so if
you do a self sovereign identity for the
post office or for any of these other
well they add in attestation to your
identity basically and and then if they
know that you're 12 then they know that
they could get sleek yeah then other
people know you're 12 yeah right but I
mean but you could maybe selectively
leaked I'm not sure maybe they they they
share it amongst each other but like
this kind of leads me to the next bit
which is that it seems that you have to
study a ridiculous amount of cutting
edge
yeah knowledge to know you know some a
quantum resistant hash functions right
there's a cell a self sovereign identity
yeah right so and there's just new and
new white papers being published in the
space all the time and so people are you
know you gave these use cases for land
there's use cases for virtual
citizenship for exchanging goods via
smart contracts you said they're smart
contract libraries there's all the
cryptocurrencies you know and you're
trying to get you're trying to help them
you know get into Japan or you're trying
to keep an idea going on of like what's
happening what do you do for parsing and
what are your favorite concepts - well I
mean yeah so users the blotching
industry hat definitely has a challenge
with user experience and onboarding new
users non-technical users older users
you know and creating because ideally
you should make an app where the person
can't even tell there's blockchain
underneath right now we're a little ways
away from that but people are trying to
do that it's take it's taking it takes
some time but people so I think we need
a lot of evangelism a lot of education
telling you know teaching people about
it everybody you know if you if you
believe in this technology you should
teach other people about it and then
it's going to take time for people to
understand it get comfortable with it
also for these are experience to improve
so that it's doesn't take someone
technical to figure out how to backup
their key and do this and you know and
do this transaction that you know that
unfortunately that will take time but I
think we will
get there and then what are they
thinking so that definitely needs to
improve also there's also some things
for people's expectations need to change
where it's like right now if I forget
the password to my bank's website I
don't lose all my money that I just call
up the central i30 the bank and they're
like oh yeah we're the central authority
we'll just issue a new past password you
know and like I get all my money back um
people are used to being stupid like you
verify your identity and then they
assume me a new password but the other
side of that is they can confiscate my
money they can lock my account the
IRIScan like tap me and say okay stop
him don't let him withdraw anything or
you know somebody could you know you
know they can you don't own it either
they're just like your you know they
have the control but they also can get
you out of problems where it's like with
a public key and a private key and a
wallet you lose that private key and
it's like oh my god I just you know lost
all this money and so people are trying
to come up with ways to get around this
problem maybe it's like I get five of my
friends to vouch for me and if they all
agree that I lost my key then I can
reconstruct my private key and that's
called social recovery for instance and
so social recovery yeah yeah so I heard
there's another one where you have a
very specific pattern that only you can
remember like kind of like if you get
immersed into like a virtual reality
environment and then you like walk a
path nobody else knows right now it's
like twelve words or 24 words but that's
still a lot to remember but yeah I could
see like condensing that 12 word phrase
into some geographic pattern or sequence
or choosing some images this is
specifically for key recoveries well
yeah recovery so you don't lose cuz if
you lose your private key technically
because there's no third party now yeah
your funds are all gone because you're
not actually holding any funds your key
just unlocks on the blockchain so
proving that those funds are yours so in
the know the blockchain is this
decentralized database the funds are in
there but my key proves that those are
mine so I don't I'm not actually holding
any funds I'm just saying oh by by with
this key I can prove in the database
that those that that's actually my funds
in them but I lose that key well now no
one can prove whose funds those are and
you're basically you know like you know
unrecoverable
so people
to understand that risk maybe there's
some recovery mechanisms that people
develop and understand the benefits and
the cons right like yeah if I lose it
maybe I'm a lot my money but I have it
in my control
I keep there's no with daily withdrawal
limit I can send it to ever I want
around the world instantly you know like
no one can stop me it's you know it's a
people fear really the self custody you
know your custody for in this a siddhis
doesn't have a cryptocurrency right like
we you said it can be like a tokenized
share in some hard asset you know or in
some revenue stream or in some business
model you know it can be all these
different things besides just a currency
yeah so it gets quite powerful and then
what and what do you when you're looking
at all of the different possibility
scape and all the white papers being
published what are you most excited
about when you see all the diversity
well that the big industry problems
being solved right now are basically
scalability privacy interoperability and
upgradability kind of their sport things
and so oh sub break humble is burger
yeah bitcoin kind of suffers on all
those or though they're trying to slowly
improve it right so like scalability the
prom with the blockchain right is that
each node traditionally each node is
verifying every transaction and so
there's just the lick if they're
basically just all like clones of each
other right which is great for security
and enforcing rules but it's like well
like after a certain level like you
reach the max and capacity of one load
or how many transactions can be put in a
block and it's like well then then like
Bitcoin people have to add more fees to
get the transactions process sooner and
so that's there are people coming up
with different solutions to that and
wasn't one of them that we discussed
because if this heartbeat of the chain
is happening every ten minutes and it's
been happening since 2008 that it's now
11 years of this right there's no I
think you were like that the changes get
so damn big it's like well now I can't
put it on a Raspberry Pi I have to have
a huge hard drive in a datacenter it has
to be SSD for the IO speed requirements
and it's like basically you want to get
has met the best decentralisation as
many people very holding storing the
Train and verifying the chain as
possible and it's like the more specific
the higher spec server you need to you
know store and verify the chain the more
centralized it's going to be because not
everybody can afford that kind of server
but there are new protocols coming out
trying to decrease those specs and
make it more decentralized the
compression well net through through
cryptography Ilana crystal new consensus
algorithm is compressed so much like
pruning out old data snapshotting data
at certain times so you can just like so
you don't have to check every block
cryptography there's a lot of different
novel approaches and other
cryptocurrencies besides Bitcoin and
Bitcoin got their own thing they're
trying to do different ways ways of
scaling scalability so when I want to
send you just a couple Satoshi which is
this break down so 100 million Satoshi
and a Bitcoin yeah it's like 10 to the
8th or something yeah and since then and
so then if I just want to send you a
couple Satoshi my know yeah you know
what's gonna wanna process right
transaction fee would be wet chai or
wouldn't be worth it wouldn't be worth
it so the scalability is also low-cost
transactions yeah that's huge yeah ok
and litecoin is one that's doing well
and well they yeah so like coin they
they yeah they they they're yeah they
they have their there they've improved
in Bitcoin it in that regard for sure ok
and then what are the other three yes so
then we said a privacy right so the
problem the blockchain to is everybody
sees that you know users well you sent
did this transaction with user 32 now
there are wait there are novel
cryptographic algorithms that can
basically like we can code that we did
this transaction such that it's provable
but you can actually see the details of
that transaction and so there are
currencies like Z cash and Manero and
other ones and even it's coming maybe to
aetherium and stuff that's called zero
knowledge proof so it's another huge
cryptographic concept zero knowledge
proof also that they they also disguise
our transaction there's different way
yeah they could they could disguise what
the value that transaction being done or
even our identities as well like in Z
Kinsey cash they don't even know how
many Z cash is in existence because it's
it's obfuscated um for instance because
everything is it's all this DK snark
encrypted confidential transactions but
so the problem with those now is that
usually they're much even lower
performance right it needs more CPU time
you know more network bandwidth and it's
like yeah you thought your blockchain
wasn't high performance now now just
like when now it's even slower just like
when these world switches
switch to HTTPS encrypted websites no
one wanted to do it because you could
only run in there like 1/10 the number
of HTTP websites that you could have the
HTTP website but now we've reached the
point where servers don't mind everybody
wants to privacy so in time they're also
they're trying that's all in an area of
active research which mostly
cryptographic and as the computational
speed increases and the algorithms
improve but then that gets the other
problems with governments like no we
want to be able to monitor and so
there's there's ways of saying like well
maybe all transactions over 10,000 are
made public to a certain entity where
other one you know but they can maybe
encode rules like that now do they want
to but so there's there's all these
different possibilities but so I don't
want it you know so scale privacy yeah
and then we said like interoperability
anyone meaning worse so it's like I have
I have Bitcoin and you have ether and
how do we swap it with each other
without going to a centralized exchange
or I have some transactions that happen
on my network me my network is processes
like you know the network for
peer-to-peer ride-sharing and yours is a
network of peer-to-peer hotel share you
know room sharing and we want to have a
user on both networks or trade a ride
for a hotel or something how do you get
those two decentralized block chains to
trust each other
right what is the best solutions right
now well there's there's new it's very
hard to do that with the existing
blockchain that didn't already have some
kind of thought put into it in advance
now they do it like auctions or people
can like truck like kind of like market
making or liquidity or oxygens or some
ways I'm not really an expert in it but
there are newer next-generation block
chains where that's being built in from
the start where it's like it has this
feature where you can have two different
block chains all you know into the same
spec that then they can like easily
bridge between each other and so there's
some coming out like that such as polka
dot and cosmos and more of these are
trying to emphasize compatibility from
day one although there still is still
evolving you know they're not fit really
completely finished yet either but
that's an area that industry is actively
working on inter up on interoperability
sounds super interesting and important
it makes it it's kind of like how we
each country has their own currency
right now and it's it's similar in that
sense like yeah I want I want to very
easily make it so that the
ride-sharing watching versus on the on
the rooms because you don't want to
trust that the reporter you can do easy
to the third-party that's what a
centralized exchanges yeah we go that
exchange and I pony up this my say this
is how much I want for my Bitcoin that's
how much you want for your ether and the
exchange batch of the transaction but
then you're back to the same problem the
exchange can send to the transaction
contribute the transaction fees same
problem yeah it's like well now we've
got like you know you've added this
centralized paradigm back again so
everybody is so there's decentralized
changes which were one way of doing that
but even just this interoperability of
transactions on different blockchain
networks that want to talk to each other
or exchange value with each other or
something
scalability privacy interoperate and now
governance or upgrade ability is what I
say the last one and so the promise
you've got this decentralized protocol
how do you vote in a new change because
basically you're saying is that like you
know we agreed that there was 21 million
Bitcoin when we made the damn thing but
maybe that was a mistake
right maybe we need to make you know 42
million and how do we how do we agree on
a change when we said this was an
immutable you know network and so there
it started out you know Bitcoin it's
like well the miners they'll have to
agree to just change the software
they're running right and if enough
miners run the new software then it kind
of takes hold otherwise it splits in you
know a hard fork or a soft work and um
that's not optimal right and it's very
slow and it's very you know political
and it can be very separating but there
are newer currencies where they're
trying to actually put this they call
governance process like on the
blockchain we're like I can say propose
making some changes to this blockchain
maybe you know changing the rules in
some way and everybody who owns that
coin can vote oh I like that change I
don't and then if it votes if when they
get enough votes then a process goes to
a testing period where they touch the
changes and then you know if that if
that succeeds then like you know a month
later it goes into this pre
implementation and then it's
automatically deployed in all the nodes
so Tesla is one coin that's kind of
pioneering this governance this this
governance mechanism for making it
amendments to the protocol but many many
are working on this problem but
amendments to the protocol that's we
this governance yeah yeah I'm grading
they call it governance but it's really
governing changes to the protocol right
there's different ways of government you
not to be confused with implementing
governance on blockchain where you could
call like like a decentralized timers or
Gurney's
or you know there's different that's
like a separate issue I'm something like
governance here is that like voting in
changes to the protocol itself which can
be very you know you know you know you
can create a lot of a lot of debate when
you're trying to change just the idea of
trying to amend something that's
immutable in code is already in itself
you know you but that's kind of what
we're experiencing right now even with
our Constitution yeah right people are
saying oh it's not dated document or or
is it you know like how do you add the
amendment which came in and did very
important pieces of addition to our code
of law here and so maybe there is
another way than to figure out how to
amend the code in block chains that make
it a little bit more easy to do the
upgrades especially to do the quantum
resistant hash functions all these types
of things like you need to amend as
technology scale and this gets into
another point where it's like you can
always take easily out and and make it
more centralized to solve any of these
problems but it's like the challenge
it's like how do you solve those
problems while maintaining
decentralization and so not every
blockchain is equal some say oh we're
just gonna you know make 21 people
decide the blocks we have these 21 block
producers and the community will vote
them in and out and we're all gonna
trust them but because there's only 21
block producers we can make a really
fast block chain so now you like
sacrifice a certain amount of
decentralization but you've added speed
but so others will say like no no you
can't do that it has to be totally like
it gets kind of philosophical as well as
really kind of political religious
battles so but everyone has different in
the block generously has a different
threshold for how much decentralization
they think is needed in all the
implications and difficulties that come
with that level of decentralization and
so it's kind of it's so if people are
always arguing about it yeah which the
discourse is what gets usually the
progress that we need do you have
anything that you know people should
know about like trying to take business
development of blockchain
decentralization companies and try and
help them gain seed in Japan right so
what does this look like when you try
and migrate
companies decentralization protocols and
infrastructures into another country
well you know it's more a matter of
building the community building the
early adopters the customers people are
going to use that protocol cause problem
with a lot of these block chains is that
they have so little real use it's mostly
the value is driven by speculation you
know they have a lot of potential but
it's like yeah until that smart contract
library is template libraries there it's
too hard for the arts person to use so
there's not a lot of use right so you
kind of speculating by buying it now
that oh it's going to be popular in the
future but so everybody wants to get my
share build a community get users get
developers get people understanding get
people building on it get apps you know
get transactions that are doing real
applications despite all these
limitations and difficulties right and
so luckily Japan being the number three
economy and also having a vibrant
cryptocurrency exchange market there's a
lot of interest in overseas companies to
appealing to Japanese businesses and
consumers there to bill developers to
start using their product you know and
so that's a lot that so I tend to try to
help those projects that want to build
their community or customer base or a
developer base in Japan and they're in
you know and vice versa - there's some
interesting Japan these projects that
want to come to America you know there's
you know there's the big isolation and
you know distance and language and
culture and customs and so it's kind of
a good niche but it can be very
challenging at times for sure
community customer base and developers
are usually the things when you're
trying to go yes the board yes you want
to build those out and try and get the
first stepping stones of your company in
that it's all like hearts and minds yeah
hearts minds and users and developers
and then also customers yeah and it's
pretty fierce the competition you know
just like Microsoft had to fame Hearst
even Ballmer video when he screams out
developers like that was like
everybody's like yeah that was so true
it's like you know they knew that like
if they have the strongest development
developer community they'll have the
best apps on their platform you know
it's the same story watching and the
best apps on the platform or or use
cases or you know it can be you know can
be an app or occurrence
or or some business process that's being
moved to a blockchain that's necessarily
have to be an app per se but they
decentralized apps are these smart
contracts that kind of govern certain
outcomes based on certain logic that's
been you know committed in advance it
could be even like a poker game where
it's like we're gonna agree on these
rules and now we make printer smart
contract so now no one can cheat you
know we can all rest assured that
someone's not going in there and look at
the other players cards or altering the
outcome in the game because we've all
put our smart cards like that could be
like an app although it's it's kind of -
smart card shop but it's also an app but
this is a this is a power-law issue
where you have in the last 10 years the
big dogs that have come in and
everyone's building apps on the big dogs
as platforms and then that's kind of
what it's like how do you what happens
when you have Google that all right so
this gets into yeah I know we talked a
bit about this the other day - this
whole like as the the centralized
service gets start there's a great
medium post on this why decentralization
matters I think it's by like Chris Dixon
or something but just just look at why
do centralization matters and it goes
into this case where it's like when one
of these like services say it's Google
say it's Twitter say it's Facebook when
they launched or say it's Apple App
Store Google Play you know that really
desperate developers oh please develop
on our platform yeah you know we'll give
you all these api's you know you can do
this and then as they get more and more
powerful they just boot off some there's
like Twitter said oh we're no longer
gonna allow you know third parties
access to our Twitter API you know
because we're so we're big enough now we
just not gonna do and all these people
with apps they all have to like go out
of business or then you kind of you out
if you don't like that 30% Commission
yeah well just don't use the platform so
like you know it turns out where they at
the beginning they quark their users
that are building the value of the
network but then as they get stronger
and stronger they're at odds those users
like and they end up starting like you
know they they start censoring them or
controlling the plot locking down the
platform controlling the fees
controlling what apps you can publish
you know all that and it kind of starts
going against the community that built
it um even you know like ride-sharing or
apartment sharing right room sharing you
know it's the same thing when they're
building the network they were really
nice and they say we're just gonna you
know cut all the drivers salaries now
because we had all this promotions when
you're starting the company but now that
we've made billions of dollars in this
company yeah screw you guys you know
like we
we're going to lower the rates you know
and in the centralized model they don't
have any any recourse any option to to
challenge that but in a decentralized
model they could actually kind of like
they can maybe even own in the network
or vote on the the policies of the
network or be rewarded in shares of the
company for you know each month that
they use the service you know there's
all these like this co-op business model
could be researched into blockchain of
course we've got lots of taxation and
legal things that need to change in the
mean time but you can see that day
probably coming where that the users of
the network gain value or the people who
provide the liquidity and the service of
the network are also haven't have a skin
in the game to get upside of the value
of the network it's not just like the
investors that get all the rewards and
the users and and liquidity providers
are forced to play in that by their
rules so that's really fascinating area
and it's going to take time to manifest
but you can see it starting to and
that's really exciting this is one of I
think one of the most important ways to
perceive what's been happening with the
emerging markets is that there's this
deep call for yeah come develop can
build with us and then once the the
power/lock kicks in and they have you
know millions and millions of people
using their service then they get the
ability to decide on what they want to
do with the censorship server the
pre-crisis yeah they said they they
approve all the apps they'd shoot they
prove they prove how much everyone's
gonna get paid they they say oh that you
know they can lock down different
aspects of their platform that compete
with them or and this in this case of
decentralisation it would be something
like a developer community that is the
one that manages the right yeah yeah you
could have some governance mechanism or
like so you had some token and the token
holders get to vote on changes or right
or there are no changes or you know or
the users are the owners yeah they can
decide the the prices
and this you know the changes to the
system and much more democratically and
then the also the range of possibilities
here people are talking about taking in
biotech so many people are talking about
taking my biometrics and just constantly
streaming them up into the cloud and
having it be on a secure immutable
digital ledger that's constantly being
parsed for Oh is there a pathology
that's developing let's make an
intervention to keep the person in peak
health you know there's like all the
stuff with agriculture and the food
industry people are like oh did this
actually come from this farm we want to
know if it came from this farm or not
and there's so many of these different
use cases decentralization in the sense
is kind of like the Internet's like the
internet just got into everything
hey I getting into everything it seems
like decentralization is getting into
everything is there anything that it's
not gonna get into that's a great
question um but what you're referring to
is this immutable property as well this
kind of opt-in how people are using it
you know those are very compelling
reasons to switch to a blockchain based
solution yeah unfortunately you know a
blockchain really is an extremely
inefficient database you know and by you
know this needs to be solved but it's
like you know storing stuff in the
blockchain well you're throwing maybe
ten thousand copies are the same thing
you know and it's like now do you need
all ten thousand copies we can we can we
start aging out old copies and so view
unfortunate there's a lot of benefits
but there also a lot of drawbacks right
now although like so we need time for
some of those to be solved but we I
think in time those will be solved and
the scalability and even like the amount
of data you can store in the blockchain
will improve and it will make more of
those possible um but we stopped still
to remind ourselves it's not like the
the panacea you know like there there
are you know cons to you know to a
blockchain one of which being all these
you know redundant copies that in this
sense could this be something like an
sick like an application-specific
integrated circuit for blockchain so
there's gonna be different blockchain
protocols that are made for agriculture
for healthcare etc stuff like that well
you know then the interoperability is
the crucial right right so so one of
these next-generation block chains that
has interoperability from the beginning
can yeah like these different so like
say you have an
your culture thing that's built on that
or supply chain thing that's built on
that same platform they can easily
interoperate but maybe if it's not a
completely different platform well can
interoperate but maybe has more
restrictions or somewhat centralized you
know there's all these different
trade-offs unfortunately but we will see
that improve for sure now the other
thing you were saying you know is there
any industry that's not gonna be
impacted yeah I mean you know you know
Finn so just look at like what has been
impacted right like you know FinTech is
the easy one because transfer value is
something that really needs this this
this property of like no cheating no
montanus immutability and no censoring
right and easy transaction let's
transfer so finances is a very easy one
it was realistic yeah like then you
gotten to other other transfers of value
maybe it's it's a transfer value of real
estate or some right or some you know
stock or equity or revenue sharing in a
physical asset or revenue stream or a
company those are also very easy to
grasp then you can show like kind of
like these inter munich immutability
aspects like you were saying like the
supply chain where stuff coming from can
we guarantee that it's never that it's
that no one has changed the the source
that this the the log of every place
this thing has been in yep maybe when
you put the data in it has to be audited
so that you make sure you're like you're
you know every day the input is kind of
like a potential weakness if you put the
wrong data in even if supply chain you
know it's like you know if they're you
know each warehouse has to be scanning
all the items that go in honestly they
have to may be audited you know and
checked but then once it's in there you
know like well no one could have changed
this this log of like all the places
this item has come from so this
immutability that's really good for
auditing as well you know auditing it
could be auditing the location auditing
any business process right this
immutability and then this uh you know
getting rid of the intermedia or well
there's so many intermediaries in our
society so you know the I think you're
gonna see more and more areas that that
that you know that that it's adopted by
reaching into maybe you know media
content creation advertising you know at
matching ads viewing ads you know
creating content attributing content
tracking royalties tracking intellectual
property
you know doing it in a way that's that's
audited and transparent and you know
like no one's you know and and and
regimented where it's not like I'm gonna
get my royalties two months later and
they might say oh we didn't approve
those because they're from this this
unauthorized country this unauthorized
user she's not gonna get those these are
a lot of problems people have now but
like putting all that blockchain makes
it very um you know codifies it yeah it
codifies it really also um IOT and robot
IOT like m2m machines talking to each
other they can send little transactions
to each other you know they can send
value or exchange data or verify their
identities yeah in AI is one the promise
AI such big datasets that you can't
really store that in a blockchain right
now maybe you can store it in a
decentralized database and link that
into the blockchain but your you know
people are working on on that so I just
want to say like not all these are
really doable using today's technology
because maybe the database the size of
the data is too big or it's too you know
too fast or you know too many
transactions but as the underlying
blockchain technology improves more of
these use cases that are possible will
materialize but maybe somebody I mean so
we're starting to see the easy ones
materialize now but there's a whole lot
more out there waiting in the wings you
know everything from like tracking
maintenance you know you could track
like airplane servicing or oilfield
service saying we have all these
different parties doing operations on a
common asset you're not really sure that
do they really clean the oil well do
they really you know take out the oil do
they do what they said they were that's
one use case that some people are doing
santhi was like an airplane so every
seeing well this part was put in here
and then it was clean there and like it
was refueled here all these different
parties were modifying that same data
but instead of having all these
different silo databases where they
could all be kind of modified by a
centralized admin put them all on
database and all in one blockchain
database like you know it's it's it's in
sync no one can go in and change the
other products these are some areas that
that people are working on now that are
feasible using today's technology but
it'll just keep expanding into many
areas but you know it still it's not the
panacea it's not you can still put bad
data in you can you know like you know I
could I could lie at when it in the
warehouse and say some other package
came and put that in so you still have
to have checks and balances when you're
when you're dealing with like physical
inputs but you know people will you know
like we have ISO certifications and we
have sanitation inspections and like I
think there'll be procedures in place
for that inside moving
today yeah but something about it seems
like there's gonna be a a better and
better application-specific oh your
protocols yeah yeah I'm not sure yeah
machine to machines kind of interesting
cuz it's gonna require a specific style
that in like there's so many machines
talking to so many there might be an
ASIC in some IOT device or some node but
the whole idea is like your your wallet
basically is just gonna run some
software on your computer or your
smartphone but yeah but the physical
hardware devices they might have some
kind of basic processing it yeah I have
some other thoughts okay so these other
thoughts are a couple like interesting
rapid-fire ones first one is so many
people have commented on this that they
think that that this that this beautiful
technology was gifted to us by something
that's not even human what is a Toshi
Nakamoto getting all mystic on me oh
yeah I know well personally I think it's
a group of people maybe government or
maybe just like anarchist type people
who wanted to have you know like
unstoppable transactions for free
economy or it could be some faction of
the government that really that's that
maybe it's some white hats who thought
like well we need to implement this so
we can rebuild the current financial
system I feel like there's got to be
some amount of divine inspiration in it
somewhere personally because it's
definitely not one person because it's
too complex to be designed by one person
you know personally I think so I'm
Althea's anything to do nationally with
Japan either I think it's a group of
individuals you know maybe some of them
did have some you know offworld
interaction or inspiration from some
other realm possibly now are they part
of a government unit like some secret
government unit or some you know some
white hat group or even just some
anarchist group that it's like yeah we
want it we want to do you know
transactions without having anybody get
in our way it could be any of those but
it's brilliant how they pulled it off
right like no one know if there was a
Satoshi Nakamoto that I'd be the
government could like go and imprison
that person and force them to change the
code or do they couldn't really do that
but like they could really cause how
because there's no person to go after
it's the beauty of it right the way it
was like at least
in phases it's like there's no person to
attack yeah you know it's just so
beautiful how like yeah I really don't
think one person could have thought all
that on their own it's too perfect right
yeah
these ways of deploying code updates to
society I think may become more and more
popular over time people may like to
just deploy things in a very anonymous
way and then make it so that people can
reap the benefits of those deployments
and I and I like I look forward to
things like build some service put it on
the blockchain and let everybody use it
right like maybe it's um you know it
could be anything you know it could be
some data market place where it's like
buyers I can go and you know upload my
biometric data and you and you can buy
it off me and it's just matching buyers
and sellers and it could just be like
this they call it a utility right where
it's like no one controls its
autonomously running it's doing all the
you know everybody can see the code so
they can know that it's not cheating
it's not to anything nefarious and it's
just you know exchanging your coins for
mine for this data and it's like you can
make this utility just put it out there
and anybody can use it
it could be on planet could be off
planet you know even on decentralisation
and blockchain related ideas that could
come to our world that people could
birth into our world anonymously might
go and make this decentralized system
and put it out there and it's kind of
selfish
yeah create some sort of new way for us
to be able to to to measure the chemo
Electric connectome in your brain and
instead of saying that you are the one
that owns it rather deployed anonymously
and see what happens with that style of
thinking yeah we should yeah that's
great yeah stuff like that's really
interesting to me a point um I also want
to know what has been your relationship
with the reason why all of this even
exists why are we even here what created
this what about nature of this reality
yeah I mean yeah good good question
obviously mankind is being more aware
more interconnected we were in this big
societal change of transparency were
like previously opaque processes are
coming to the light
data leaks so easily um people share
information that's part of it but people
also are more curious you know they're
raising their vibration they're more
they're more more a lot you know more
cut more aware more conscious and I
think there's all that's that's the
backdrop that that we're looking at and
then as we're becoming more aware we
start to realize we'll wait
I kind of gave away too much of my power
to that authority over there and they're
really ripping me off they're just like
you know BOTS selling that reselling the
service to me but they're charging this
much more and they're not really
providing much value I didn't realize
like there's there's all these like
leeches like what is it um rent so they
say in the industry
ransom Burnie yeah rent seeking
intermediaries - one is um yeah
- basically peer-to-peer so it's like
there's always rent seeking
intermediaries in our society and
they're taking this hugely tax on all
poor transactions or prosperity and
they're saying that money where you know
are they giving it like oh they're like
the rich families or these powerful
elites or the deep state or whoever
right this this money is being funneled
somewhere but we're not getting you know
but then you can actually see well whit
this and they're not only that they
could be interfering with the
transaction censoring them changing them
and it's like well gee I never realized
all the intermediaries in our society
that are you know charging these huge
fees and doing very little no in
fairness those processes used to be a
lot harder you know like he used to be
met you know sending international bank
transfer I'm sure like back you know
before when the computers was getting
started actually was a lot of manual
labor and stuff but it's not on the
point where it's basically all automated
but they're still charging these
exorbitant rates because they can you
know and then they get these these rent
seeking intermediaries who are ingrained
there may be protected by laws or
business relationships and they're just
getting all this money for doing nothing
maybe it's credit card transaction
processing fees or maybe it's you know
money transfer fees or whatever and it's
like are you really doing 3% worth of
work you know for that my Orion it's you
know probably not but people are
awakening to that fact they're also
awakening to like the debasement or you
know the inflation of our monetary
supply and all that and and they're kind
of taking their their their their their
self sovereignty back right now and it
kind of fits perfectly into blot wall
you know using blockchain and
decentralization you actually can
improve a lot of these processes which
you've now awakened to how bad day
have been for all these years you know
and so that's kind of the backdrop I see
I also like the words that you use there
you said that the nature of the reality
is becoming more alive it's becoming
more interconnected and then there was
this P there's these ways that we get
like oh well why am i paying so much
money to the third to the third party
and then you kind of wake up more and
you probably create solutions to that
issue that arose in as part of this
creation that we're embedded in another
question I think is important to ask you
do you think that humanity is a
biological bootloader for digital super
intelligence well I'm not a believer
particularly in the singularity you know
I think I think people tried you I think
technology is kind of as much as I love
technology I think this whole like man
merging with machine I think is very
against like spirituality because really
I think we ourselves can do a lot of
these I mean there might be some you
know conversion I don't think it's gonna
be like a cyborg you know I think some
of this and they've got these brain
machine interface stuff they're working
on but I think a lot of that like if we
become more spiritual and tap into our
own innate abilities we can do a lot
that stuff without having your lying
machines and so people are like well
just do it all machines but it's like
well you could or you could become more
aware more more intuitive more trusting
your own feelings more psychic or
whatever if you just stopped and
meditated more or you trusted yourself
more and I think that I hope that that
will also gain in in popularity and also
awareness so that people don't think
like I have to I feel like there's this
feeling like I have to rely on
technology to make myself a better human
but I think really people can look
inside and and we can evolve now I'm
still working on this personally you
know it's not like I can I'm not you
know I'm not like psychic I don't have a
lot of these abilities yet but I feel
like we all can develop these abilities
a lot more than we are and not have to
rely on technology as much as people
think we're gonna have to rely on
technology so I'm not really like a fan
of this whole singularity and machines
you know making man better because I
think like that's going to come with a
lot of other risks because those
machines are also able to control
or people will control the machines or
you're gonna give up some humanity or
you know I really think that it's kind
of the wrong way to go personally but
you know this is all kind of conjecture
at this point okay
how about what about the deepest emotion
that you've ever felt um you know I
don't to say probably the deepest
emotion is how do you have kids you know
this is kind of cliche it's now I'm not
even really sure how to answer that
question but probably you know like you
know there's this whole thing of service
to others versus service to self and
that's part of the human evolution is
that like as you become more service to
others you are fulfilling your mission
here on earth and what is one of the
things that forces you to be service to
others but having a kid it's like you
can't expect that baby to like do any of
this stuff you're gonna have to do stuff
right some no matter how selfish a
person you are you know like you're
gonna have to be less selfish if you
have a kid you're specially for it you
know from us but also for dads right and
so that whole path on like trying to
give service to others is is kind of
tied into this you know like that you
know once you kind of reel anyway it's
kind of you have to be comfortable with
it's like oh man you know now I have to
spend all this and you look at like how
parents who have problem kids and
they're with that kid for like 30 40
years still like going at it like you
know it's like amazing how you know you
know you're in that other life you know
equal or ahead of their own and it's
just like they're not getting anything
in return you know they're just doing it
out of the goodness of their heart like
that I think that emotion and that
transition to service to others is kind
of this like probably the one of the
deepest lessons that that we learn you
know it's kind of as you get all as you
get older you kind of get wiser but it's
true like some people just never they
don't know they're just always super
selfish but most people as they get
older they get less selfish and the
other they volunteer or they have kids
or all that or the universe will force
you to in some way to if you're holding
up many times what has been your
relationship with
the with creation or with the divine or
with God or with infinite consciousness
or whatever you want to call it what has
been your relationship with that as
you've grown through your life well I'm
lucky I was never subjected to the dogma
of an organized religion I did go to
Sunday School like my mom wanted me to
experience stuff so I think she put me
in Sunday school one summer and I like
you know excitedly studied the Bible and
like you know but I never we never like
it wasn't like you have to do this or we
never went to church every week and I
feel like my mom was very metaphysical
as well as what it's like um
you know curious about many different
disciplines so she would always you know
research them all and kind of you know
take her best out of all these different
lines I think that's a kind of cool
attitude um so that's kind of how I I
was was raised and you know but for a
longest time I was you know so I was so
of course I'm not trying to knock all
religion a lot of organized religion is
used to control people and there's a lot
of dogma there's a lot of mankind
you know man using it for other reasons
to control her man um in my opinion and
I'm not saying all religion is bad but
I'm glad you know I was interested in
that dogma and that whole like going to
it and FaceTime and you know i i'd much
rather like find my own path and what
did you find in that yeah you know you
know i there was a period time i felt
like well who knows if there's a god I
must be agnostic go through these phases
oh I think I'm agnostic but no I'm not
really saying there is a God but life is
not a coincidence right like it's too
perfect to be a coincidence night I
think speaks of that a little more oh
yeah too perfect to be a coincidence
yeah I I'm I don't want to get started
on a whole long discussion here but
there's you know really I think what
I've loved the realization that I've
come to is that this is really a
classroom right and we come here to live
certain lessons and evolve and it's not
that like this is the only game in town
it's not like this was just we just
happen to like evolve from like an
amoeba to a person and there's only one
place in the world like this and we're
so special and I really think it's it's
it's everything every day every
experience is teaching you in some way
and you know it doesn't make it any
easier
at least you can kind of like try to
have a good mindset to be a good student
you know be a game of life it's hard
knocks but you know we're here we might
as well make the best of it but I feel
like there's there's definitely the
rules of our reality all that I feel
yeah it's definitely been set up by some
higher force whatever that is and we are
here experiencing it because it's fun
and it's educational and it's it's
giving us
yeah and we're growth right and and
we're just trying to grow as souls and I
love that Jim yeah that's beautiful
you're really got every moment is a
beautiful experience of some sort some
sort of a lesson something to learn some
way for this creation to experience
itself and yeah yeah yeah exactly
and so all of us having that here and
wherever else is such a beautiful
process of growth and such is not easy
it's hard work right hard knocks but but
it but it's fun right like how would you
know like you know how it felt like to
hug somebody or to go on a swing or you
know write or watch a movie if there was
no concept of time you know or have all
these experiences right like it's it's
definitely a thrill but it doesn't make
it any easier how do you um help your
your your girls for brilliant yes yes
it's now how do you yeah here like wow I
should if I fast so how do you um help
with the rapidly changing world that
we're going to with all the different
technologies and stuff and also that
statement that we just talked about with
this being a classroom this creation
being classroom how how can how do you
work those things into your yeah be
honest you know they're so young we
haven't done a lot yet but I think kind
of understanding cause-and-effect and
like your actions and the outcome they
have on other people you know I think
kids are by their nature are just
selfish because of course like that's
how you are when you're young you just
want more and you want be gratified and
you want what you want and so but you
can hopefully instill upon this like
well there's a limited resource and if
you don't if you have
somebody else doesn't have it or you can
share your Mele be limited resources
somebody else or you you might do this
action but look how it's gonna affect
that person kindness cause and effect
and sharing I think they can kind of
start to grasp those concepts now
hopefully they they resonate with it and
it doesn't cause them to like become
more selfish you know I haven't quite
this is a chapter I'm still barely
writing I feel but I kind of look at it
from that perspective you know and like
teaching them the value of life you know
the value no value of work and the
impact of their actions and and you know
and trying to help other people some of
all that but you know it's not easy and
I'm not you know I'm still I'm still
figuring out a lot of it I mean there's
still how young is too young I don't
know you know but hopefully they can at
least see what the parents are doing
emulate that so yeah and then and then
how about we we we we have to ask you
the the questions that we ask at the end
of the show right the first one is are
we in a simulation well depends how you
define simulation but yeah I mean life
could just be I mean it's like a game
right like we basically say oh I think
yeah it could be somebody it's like here
all the rules of the simulation like
you're doing some mr. Urich simulation
of how the wind particles are affecting
the Sun and changing the weather it's
like well yeah I mean here's the laws of
physics here's like the laws of gravity
here's the laws of you know like cause
and effect harm or whatever and it's
like yeah now go and play in that
sandbox so it's like your internet so
maybe you have this free will to kind of
you know choose the path in this
simulation but you're still governed by
this set of rules which were kind of
inescapable at least at this point maybe
as a collective eventually we modify
them but they seem pretty fixed to me
but maybe as our consciousness evolves
we we got we see governance and we we we
vote in a new upgrade to the system I
don't know about that but or we create
quadrillions of simulations with new
ideas or maybe another way of looking at
it so I do feel like in if you call that
a simulation then yeah maybe it is a
simulation but I mean it's not like
someone I don't think it's like people
predetermined our path through it but
maybe there were certain outcomes which
were more probable just like you know
that wind particle it's 80 percent
chances gonna blow up
you know 20% chance it's gonna blow down
here maybe the same in our life like we
knew about these probabilities and then
we go in and then we just start you know
finding a path through government being
governed by these rules and so maybe
that is a simulation but it's not like
it was a predetermined thing that
somebody else is just running or
something what do you think is most
beautiful in this creation well I mean
really the beauty of nature I guess you
know just like how every you know it's
like every moment has some beauty in it
maybe it's the clouds maybe it's the
that the the trees the branches the
leaves you know like all these all that
you know like there's such beauty and
you know the selves the organism the
shape that they know everything is just
it's you know it's a the I guess the
design of what is it um what's the word
I'm looking for
Gestalt or whatever where it's like
every every little you know also get
stopped but also fractal where it's like
yeah you know well you know the animal
has these organs and these cells and
these enough to wild babies in this DNA
and then that repeats in this pattern
it's just like all this the way all
these different complex systems all
relate and also just like the beauty to
watch you know the beauty to listen to
the to music or birds or see the sunset
it's like every every moment has some
beauty in it if you just you know
observe it and so I think that's mmm
that's that's really you know fun I wish
we could kind of see the full spectrum
of light and maybe hear more frequencies
and have a little bit more awareness to
all the EMF out there but still we have
a pretty good you know range of vision
and maybe augmenting our senses towards
that yeah I hope so I think agreed you
can totally in in every experience every
moment there's beauty to be seen yeah
and maybe some have more like the
children and things like that that
you've experienced that have had maybe a
little bit more a different type of
beauty or yeah natural you know they
they're unreserved you know yeah yeah
just pretense yeah on yeah they're not
they're not they you know they're it's
very hard even they of course they can
they can eventually pretend but
they're much more real yeah this has
been so interesting Jim thank you for
coming on our program yeah I really
enjoyed this talk yeah thank you for
having me and good luck with your
channel yeah good job
thanks thanks yeah we get the
opportunity to sit down with people like
you and help share these messages
Congrats on all the great work also on
trying to build the new world with
blockchain and decentralization and also
on trying to bring it around the world
to places like Japan also everyone have
more conversations with your friends
families chorus and people online about
these types of subjects have more
conversations about decentralization and
their future with technologies like
blockchain check out the links in the
bio below to Jim on linkedin and on
twitter check those out and also support
the artists the entrepreneurs the
spiritual leaders the organizations in
your communities that you believe even
support them help them grow you can find
all of simulations links below all of
our links check those out and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world thank you very
much for tuning in we love you very much
and we will see you soon thank y'all
[Music]